first on saturday without any republican
support
the u.s senate passed their own version
of the 1.9
trillion dollar so-called emergency
coveted relief bill but unfortunately
this far left spending spree socialist
spending spree
yeah has next to nothing to do with
emergency coveted relief
according to senator ted cruz only nine
percent
of the bill is actually dedicated to
health care
some by the way foreign health care a
bulk of the spending includes a
350 billion dollar budget bailout
that will go to irresponsible blue
states
complements of hard-working taxpayers
from
responsible red states who elect
let's see governors and assemblies
and senates that actually balance their
budget
keep taxes low fund their pensions yeah
you get the idea
legislation also provides one time a
fourteen hundred dollar payment to
certain people
while many americans will not be
eligible if you are a felon you will
likely qualify for payments from behind
bars it's going to be great for the
commissary business in prison
this includes convicted murderers by the
way many illegal
immigrants could also qualify as well as
other non-citizens
and as we have previously reported
hundreds of billions of dollars in this
so-called
emergency spending bill will not be
touched until after 2022
some until after 2024 and some
even as late as 2028 some emergency
according to joe biden this bill is
really good for our economy
or at least that's what he tried to say
during some rare
public remarks and as always it goes
predict
predictably well not perfectly
one more thing the vast majority of
economists
left right and center from wall street
to the
to the private private
uh uh economic
polling initiatives the economist
as i said left right and center say
in addition to the needs that people
have we need this to grow the economy
kind of scary when you think putin is
watching hostile regime
president xi hostile regime he's
watching the mothers are watching kim
jong-un are watching
uh what the hell is going on with joe
biden uh
we'll update you we'll have our update
for the day coming up now earlier he
literally forgot
he forgot the name of his own secretary
of defense
i don't know maybe nobody wrote it down
on a special card that he always carries
with him
he also referred to the pentagon as you
know that
outfit over there so he forgot the name
of the pentagon
don't believe me we've got the painful
tape you decide
just want to thank you both and i want
to thank the
the former general i keep calling in
general my
my uh the guy who runs that outfit over
there
i want to make sure we thank the
secretary
for all he's done to try to implement
what we've just talked about
the general that runs that thing over
there the pentagon
i still think for getting endowed by the
thing oh you know
the thing doubt by the creator joe
god the creator of everything
i think we know why joe biden has not
conducted a single press conference nor
has he given us a date
for a state of the union address he's
clearly
not capable they've got to really build
to a crescendo here but the bottom line
is
the narrative remains the same the
foreign press is now
saying it openly that he looks weak and
frail and is struggling cognitively
and now it's pretty much every day and
every day it seems to get worse
and worse and worse and we're just well
we're the people that are actually
honest and truthful
rest of the media said it about reagan
said it about mccain
why can't they bring it up here did they
not see what we just played you
according to press secretary jen saki
he's just so busy
he doesn't have time to hold the press
conference we're supposed to believe
this
well first as all of you know the
president takes questions several times
a week
uh he took questions actually twice
yesterday uh which
is an opportunity for the people
covering the white house to ask him
about whatever news is happening on any
given day
we look forward to holding a full press
conference in the coming weeks before
the end of the month
but this president came in during a
historic
crisis two historic crises and i would
say that his focus again
is on getting recovery and relief to the
american people
and he looks forward to continuing to
engage with all of you
hey jen you're going to need to circle
back with a better lie than that
i personally i'm not buying it too busy
what do you mean by too busy too busy to
take
questions communicate with we the
american people
um joe that's part of your job you're
the president
remember this is getting embarrassing
now keep in mind every single modern-day
president has given a full-on press
conference
by this point in their presidency trump
he spoke almost daily to the mob and the
media that hated him
all previous presidents somehow found
the time
that joe can't bind instead of a press
conference on thursday joe biden
apparently will be
marking the one-year anniversary of
covet shutdowns
with what it will be a heavily scripted
and practiced
quote prime time address